[Music]
lit is timeless my guy like in terms of
this party is lit like its parent you
know I mean with fires like that sweater
is fire or it's lit but it makes more
sense to say it's fire like that's a
piece like it's fire like saying oh this
party's fire like that's weird like you
could say it but like you'd rather say
lid o got ass lots of fat
alright so that ass is a lot of things
it's a question it's a statement and
it's an answer like oh that ass oh you
got not that ass or like that ass you
not I mean so that ass is a classic
classic New York statement means you're
dead [ __ ] serious like that ass or
like are you dead [ __ ] serious or
like not dead puffing seriously [ __ ] no
AF is so quiet for that bro see people
be like arm woke AF like oh dude whoa
first off ain't nobody whoa I hate woke
Twitter people like T like it's more
than that like you got to think deeper
like all those like ultra twitter like
everything's that deep people I use whoa
when I'm roasting somebody like oh like
what so what you woke now like but I'll
never say like oh that person's move ah
that's a classic catch a fade that means
I'm at the phages [ __ ] like I'm at the
fading away I'm like the [ __ ] knock
you out like that means you bought the
scrap oh oh head as y-yeah head eyes
that's a classic like when you be
roasting people used to be like I get
you five dollar pizza box had a son like
Oh Chuckie Cheese token bill - like it's
bill guys head eyes neck eyes York got a
lot of acid look ill - in the face sighs
I get your bum ass out of here that's
the thing too
[Music]